JOEL LEWIS: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
In lecture, you've been
learning about line integrals
and computing them around
curves and closed curves
and in various different ways.
So here I have some problems
on line integrals for you.
So in all cases I want C to
be the circle of radius b.
So b is some constant,
some positive constant.
It's the circle of radius
b centered at the origin,
and I want to orient
it counterclockwise.
And then what I'd
like you to do is
for each of the following
vector fields F,
I'd like you to compute the line
integral around C of F dot dr.
So in the first case,
where F is x*i plus y*j.
In the second, where F is g
of x, y times x*i plus y*j.
So here g of x, y is
some scalar function.
But you don't know a
formula for this function.
So your answer might be in
terms of g, for example.
You can assume it's a
continuous, differentiable
nice function.
And then the third one,
F is minus y*i plus x*j.
Now before you start,
I want to give you
a little suggestion,
which is often
when we're given a line
integral like this,
the first thing you want
to do is jump in and do
a parameterization right
away for the curve,
and then you get a normal
single variable integral.
So what I'd like you to
do for these problems
is to think about the
setup and think about
whether you can do this
without ever parameterizing
C, so without ever substituting
in cosine and sine or whatever.
So for all three
parts of this problem.
So if you can use some
sort of geometric reasoning
to save yourself a
little bit of work
without ever going to
the parameterization.
So why don't you pause the
video, spend some time,
work that out, come back, and
we can work it out together.
Hopefully you had some luck
working on these problems.
Let's get started.
So let's do the
first problem first.
Let's think about what this
vector field F looks like.
This first vector field.
So let me just draw a
little picture over here.
So here's our
circle of radius b.
And this vector field F
given by x*i plus y*j.
At every point (x,
y), the vector F
is the same as the position
vector of that point.
So over here the
vector's like that.
Over here, the
Up here, the vector
is like that.
So these are just a
few little values of F
that I've drawn in there.
And so down here,
say, F is like that.
So in particular, so that's
just sort of-- you know,
if you wanted, you could
draw in some more vectors,
get a full vector field picture.
So the thing to observe
here is that a circle
is a really nice curve.
So the circle has the
property that the position
vector at a point is orthogonal
to the tangent vector
to the circle.
At every point on the
circle, the tangent vector
to the circle is perpendicular
to the position vector.
So that means it's perpendicular
to F, because F is the same,
in fact, but is parallel
to the position vector.
So in Part a, you
have that F dot
the tangent vector
to your curve is
equal to zero at every
point on the entire curve.
All right?
So your field F dot your
tangent vector is always zero.
So that means that the
integral around C of F dot dr,
well, we know that dr is T ds.
So this is F dot T ds.
But that's just zero.
It's just an integral and the
integrand is zero everywhere.
And whenever you take a definite
integral of something that's
zero everywhere, you get zero.
So this is just zero right away.
We didn't have to parameterize
the curve or anything.
We just had to look
at this picture
to sort of understand
that this kind of field,
it's called a
radial vector field,
where the vector F is always
pointed directly outwards.
When you integrate a
radial vector field
around a circle
centered at the origin,
you get zero, because the
contribution at every point
is zero.
So that's Part a.
Part b is actually
exactly the same.
If we look back at our
formula over here in Part b,
we have that F is given by
some function g of x, y times
x i hat plus y j hat.
Well, what is this
g of x, y doing?
It's just rescaling.
It's telling you at
every point you can scale
that vector by some amount.
So if we looked over at this
picture, maybe over here
you would scale some of
these vectors to be longer,
and over here they
might be shorter,
or you might switch
them to be negative,
but you don't change the
direction of any vector
in the field from Part a.
You just change their length.
So you still have a
radial vector field.
And you still have the
property that at every point
on our curve, the tangent
vector to the curve
is orthogonal to the vector
F. So the tangent vector
is orthogonal to F, so
that means you again
have F dot T is equal to zero.
And so F dot dr is
also equal to 0 ds,
and so when you integrate
that, you just get zero.
So that's also what
happens in Part b.
So Part b, I'm just
going to write ditto.
The exact same reasoning applies
in Part b as applied in Part a.
And you also get
zero as your integral
without having to
parameterize, without having
to do any tricky
calculations at all.
All right.
So let's now look at Part c.
I'm going to draw
another little picture.
So in Part c,
there's your curve.
At the point (x,y)-- so I'm
going to draw some choices of F
again.
So in Part c, at
the point (x,y),
your vector field F is
minus y i hat plus x j hat.
Now if you draw
that on the picture
here, over there
that's that vector.
Over here, so at the
point (0,1), say,
that gives you the
vector [-1, 0].
So that's horizontal
to the left.
Here are some more.
There's one there,
there's one there.
There's another one
over here and so on.
In fact, what you'll notice
is that this vector F is just
parallel to the tangent vector
of the circle everywhere.
This field is a
tangential field.
It's always pointing
parallel to the curve.
OK?
It's perpendicular to
the position vector.
It's in the same direction
as the tangent vector
at every point.
So this is something that
you've seen before, I think.
That this vector
field is giving you
a sort of nice rotating motion.
You know, at every point it's
circulating counterclockwise.
So what does that mean?
Well, again, it's not exactly
the same as Part a and b,
but again we'll be able
to compute this integral
without parameterizing.
Why?
Because F dot T in this
case-- well, so, let's see.
What is the norm of F?
The magnitude of F is
just the square root of
(x squared plus y squared).
So on our circle of radius b,
that means the magnitude of F
is b.
And the magnitude of T, the
unit tangent vector, is 1,
and they point in
the same direction.
So when you have two
vectors that point
in the same direction,
their dot product
is just the product
of their magnitudes.
So that means F dot
T is equal to b.
This is a constant.
F dot T is equal to b.
So when you integrate
around the circle, F dot dr,
well, this is equal
to the integral
around a circle of F dot the
tangent vector with respect
to arc length.
But this integrand, F
dot the tangent vector,
is this constant b.
So you're integrating
over the curve b ds.
And when you integrate
a constant ds,
well, that just gives
you the total arc length.
So this is b times
the total arc length.
And this is a
circle of radius b.
So that's b times 2 pi b, which
we could also write as 2 pi
b squared.
So there you go.
So in this third case, you have
a nice tangential vector field.
So that means the
integrand actually
works out to be constant.
Because the integrand
is constant,
we don't ever have to
parameterize the curve.
We can just use the
fact that we already
know its arc length in order
to compute this integral.
Again, we could do
all of these integrals
if we wanted by
parameterizing the circle,
by x equals b cosine
t, y equals b sine t,
and going through and writing
this as an integral from t
equals 0 to 2 pi, and so on.
But these are
examples of problems
where it's helpful to think
about what's going on first,
see if you can understand the
geometry of your situation.
And sometimes you'll have
a problem like this where
you'll-- either in this class
or elsewhere in your life--
where something that might
seem complicated has a simple
geometric explanation.
And so when that
does happen, it's
nice when you can
take advantage of it.
Sometimes that won't
happen and sometimes you'll
have to do the parameterization
and the computation.
But in these cases we have
these nice three examples
where with a radial
vector field,
you get that the
integrand is always zero,
or with a tangential
vector field, you have
that the integrand is constant.
All right.
So, I'll stop there.